it's just something we don't like to
think about no one talks about it no one
really wants to address it my husbands
very much don't want to talk about it
no you're fine i don't want to talk
about my girl too much with them because
i don't want to make them feel more
unhappy
it's even more difficult if you're faced
with somebody that you
love who's got a diagnosis and then
you have to start this conversation you
don't have the language
because you've never talked about it you
don't have the familiarity you don't
know how to open the question
[Music]
in our society we're often encouraged to
plan for our lives planning for our
births
planning for different operations if
they need to happen and also
as an extension of that starting to plan
for our end-of-life care
and that's increasingly important
because more of us have a period where
we are
dying rather than just suddenly dead so
there's a chance to think about what
that period will look like when those
questions
are looking back at you and someone is
saying
what do you want it makes you really sit
down
and think about all the places that you
know you might want to have your ashes
scattered
or whether you want to die in hospital
or whether you want to come home and die
you know what are you going to do with
your animals you know
who's going to look after your husband
when you've gone families might
make the assumption that they will be
able to speak on behalf of their loved
one
and it's not an automatic thing that
they can do that
it's important that they legally
nominate a family member by making them
a lasting power of attorney for health
and welfare
[Music]
the comfort knowing that my parents
have our attorney and they can make
those decisions when i'm not
able to rather than a doctor or
somebody who doesn't know me very well
just nudging doctors in the right
direction to actually
do this but don't do any more or this is
not what i would have wanted it's
incredibly helpful
legally we can't demand certain
treatments but we can definitely refuse
treatment so
people can say they don't want to be
resuscitated or they don't want to have
artificial nutrition i think a funeral
plan is
extremely helpful carl had made one my
husband before he died
so we did know what he wanted in his
funeral
and what he didn't want that kind of
practical thing was
it was such a comfort to the family
allow
them to grieve for you
instead of having to worry about the
what ifs
what if we've done this wrong
we don't turn up and say let's talk
about death
or you know tell me what you want if um
if i tell you that you're dying you sent
me your advanced care plan booklet and
i've i felt i filled that in up to a
point although when it came to these you
know if you want your
window open or shut or your light on or
what about your hygiene i thought no
i can't even think about that um
but it is simply a case of getting
things together
so that really so it's easy for my
family
by documenting this information now you
are at the center and we
as professional and your close ones and
family will do
the best we can to to make sure you have
the care
and the preferences you want it's really
important that you tell your gp
or your health care provider what your
preferences are if they relate to
medical options
it's important to let your friends and
family know where they can find that
document
if it's in a particular part of your
house
disabled young people don't necessarily
want to be focusing on
more planning which is around their
illness or their disability
so personally for me i feel like i've
spent
a lot of time kind of negotiating my
health negotiating the support that i
receive the care that i receive my
diagnoses
and so i want to spend any extra time
or extra energy that i have really
living and making sure that i'm doing
the things which i think are important
within healthcare these days there's an
expectation
both from healthcare professionals and
patients that people can have a say
about what's important to them
however that can put a lot of pressure
on people to make sense of quite
a vast array of information and at a
time when they actually might want to
defer the decision-making to someone
else
if we have to and you're not able to
tell us what you want
we will do what we think is best for you
from what we know
it's not a yes you've got a plan or no
you haven't it's
it's more of a kind of evolution of
thinking
you can revisit them and change them as
your life is progressing or as your
values are changing it's a true gift of
love because
you're taking away that burden put your
wishes down
file away and forget about it and focus
on the important bits of living and
getting on with life
we insure our house we insure our cars
we insure our pets why are we not
insuring ourselves
and nobody's gonna say well i think i
didn't say what do you want me
right because i did and it's there on
paper
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already
hit the subscribe button and click the
bell to get a notification each time we
upload a new video